"Will 'Black Adam' be worth the wait for the
millions...and millions of The Rock's fans?
Or will it be Rock Bottom? Here's the lowdown."
With a release date fast approaching, marketing
has been building anticipation for Dwayne
"The Rock" Johnson's latest box office smash,
"Black Adam." As expected, the first official
trailer debuted in time to pump up audiences
during the latest summer Blockbuster hits.
A second trailer debuted for audiences
at the 2022 San Diego Comic-Con.
With powerful action and strikes of
lightning, these glimpses of "Black Adam"
offered audiences some clues as to the tone
and direction of the feature. Most notably,
the latest DCEU film offers an appropriately
contrasting energy to the 2019 outing,
"Shazam!" With both titular characters
closely linked in the comic book lore,
illuminating their differences as natural enemies
is a strategic maneuver. The light-hearted,
often immature tone of "Shazam!" is in line
with the theme of a child-turned-superhero.
"Good, yeah, good. You're
really on top of this stuff."
Meanwhile, the trailers for "Black
Adam" decisively point out that its
headliner is 5,000 years old
and correspondingly grumpy.
Further dissecting the trailer, audiences can
expect a detailed backstory of how Black Adam
gained his powers, mixed with the struggles
the character faces as an immortal entity.
Additionally, the sneak peeks include
a new team of heroes for the DCEU,
the Justice Society of America. Included
in the group's ranks is character Dr. Fate,
as well as the first looks at Hawkman, Cyclone,
and Atom Smasher. How this team interacts with
the leading character is certain to be a
driving factor of the entire film. Based
on the source material, the inclusion of
Sarah Shahi as Isis may imply a romantic
subplot that changes how Black Adam behaves
in this film and any other future projects.
DC has been planning the character's big screen
breakout for a very long time. Its road to a
theatrical release has been very much of the
long and winding sort. That's primarily a result
of the DCEU re-evaluating the way they approach
their cinematic world in the wake of the colossal
misfire that was "Justice League." It also had
to do with DC wanting to release "Shazam!" before
introducing that hero's arch enemy. Finally, it
was also a late-in-the-game executive decision to
the effect that Black Adam was a rich enough
character to support a solo film of his own.
Initially, "Black Adam" was scheduled to hit
theaters on December 22, 2021, as something of
a nice holiday gift for DC fans far and wide.
Of course, as with many other entertainment
projects large and small, the COVID-19 pandemic
significantly delayed its filming schedule,
landing it a new release date of July 29, 2022.
Then, the film's megastar himself announced in
March that "Black Adam" was pushed back
amidst an overall reshuffling by Warner
Bros. of its upcoming major films'
release dates, according to Deadline.
Currently, "Black Adam" is scheduled to
premiere in theaters on October 21, 2022.
Obviously, the one and only Dwayne "The Rock"
Johnson will star in "Black Adam." Mr. Johnson
has been quite vocal about wanting to play
the role since first circling it back in 2014.
DC's and Warner Bros.' haphazard attempts to play
catch up in the universe-building approach likely
hindered the development of several other DC
properties, including Johnson's "Black Adam."
Now that the DCEU has found its footing via hits
like "Wonder Woman," "Aquaman," and "Shazam!,"
Johnson will finally get to bring "Black
Adam" to comic-loving audiences everywhere.
Johnson is so excited to get into character
that he's been teasing fans via Instagram
about getting into fighting shape for the
movie ever since his casting was announced.
And yes, it appears he'll be getting even
more buff than usual for the project.
Despite the fact the two heroes are
perennial rivals, it seems Warner Bros.
has no intention of bringing Zachary Levi's
Billy Batson-slash-Shazam into the mix just
yet. And Levi himself has said that the two
foes likely won't square off until "Shazam 3."
Joining Johnson is a cast that includes a mix
of well-known names and newcomers alike. As of
the film's most recent casting announcement, via
Deadline, "Black Adam" will feature Noah Centineo
as the heroic Atom Smasher. Pierce Brosnan will
play Justice Society of America member Dr. Fate.
Aldis Hodge is team leader Hawkman. Quintessa
Swindell is tornado-based hero Cyclone.
Sarah Shahi plays a significant comic
book character named Adrianna Tomaz.
Marwan Kenzari, Bodhi Sabongui,
Mohammed Amer, James Cusati-Moyer,
and "Young Rock" lead Uli Latukefu will all appear
in capacities that have yet to be disclosed.
"I'm ready. We can start
right now if you want to."
While we have some idea of who will
be appearing in the "Black Adam" movie
alongside Mr. Rock, we currently know
next-to-nothing about the film's plot.
DC and Warner Bros. are remaining fiercely
tight-lipped about this aspect of the project.
However, despite the fact that we don't
quite know exactly what Team DC has in
store for the "Black Adam" movie, there's still
some things we can glean ahead of any official
story announcements. First and foremost, it's
worth noting that "Black Adam" will indeed be
the character's first appearance in the DCEU. As
such, it's a safe bet that "Black Adam" will serve
as an origin story of sorts. That said, Johnson
shared the film's opening scene during the 2021 DC
Fandome event, and in that footage Black Adam
is already an established superhuman within
the film's fictional world. So, while the
movie may simply begin chronologically with
Black Adam's reawakening, as suggested by
this clip, it's also possible that it might
jump back in time after its opening scene
to establish the character's conception.
Per ScreenRant, Johnson himself has said that
he'll be playing up the antihero side of Black
Adam's story rather than his villainous
tendencies over the course of the film.
He may even be pushing the character
into more straight-up hero territory,
which should make for an interesting showdown
when he eventually meets up with Shazam.
Or, dare we say, even
Superman — on the big screen.
"Holy moly."
What would "The Dark Knight"
be without Christopher Nolan?
Or would "Wonder Woman" have packed
the same punch without Patty Jenkins?
It is becoming more and more relevant to have a
great director behind a superpowered blockbuster.
Thankfully, "Black Adam" found its director
in Spanish-born Jaume Collet-Serra.
Best known for horror films such as "Orphan"
or the Paris Hilton-led "House of Wax,"
the director previously worked with Dwayne Johnson
on the 2021 Disney feature "Jungle Cruise." In an
interview with Deadline, Collet-Serra explained
how he ended up on the DC comics project,
"I gravitated toward the origin story
of this unconventional character."
The seasoned director further detailed
the morality of the subject and plot,
describing "Black Adam" as the, quote, "Dirty
Harry" of superheroes. That understanding of the
story clearly resonated with the star, as The Rock
also confirmed at CinemaCon that the 1971 Clint
Eastwood feature was the inspiration and, quote,
"north star" for the direction of "Black Adam."
"Black Adam" is a project that has been in
the works for an extremely long-time — at
least compared to other comic book adaptations. As
far back as 2014, The Rock confirmed via Twitter
that he would be taking the role of the antihero,
Black Adam. That same year, DC set its intentions
of repeating Marvel's success by manufacturing
its own cinematic universe. And despite Dwayne
Johnson being tied to the franchise, the
character unexpectedly failed to appear in
any of the previous outings, including "Shazam!"
where a cameo would have made logical sense.
The exception, of course, is his recent
Black Adam cameo in an animated DC film.
Released in 2022, "DC League of Super-Pets"
features a collection of superhero animal
friends facing their own adventure.
Coincidentally, The Rock stars in the
film as Superman's lovable canine, Krypto. And
as the film premiered, the former wrestler was
quick to reveal an after-credit scene featuring
none other than Black Adam and his own pet dog.
Regardless of DC's rollercoaster of success
at the box office, The Rock has remained
an advocate for the "Black Adam" movie. The
footballer-turned-wrestler-turned-actor has been
wide-open about what draws him to the character,
which he surprisingly refers to as a superhero,
despite Black Adam historically
being written as the villain.
With Johnson's monumental success as a movie
star, the actor likely had his choice of comic
book heroes to portray after 2008's "Iron Man"
initiated the rise of adaptations. However, he has
chosen to champion "Black Adam" into existence. He
is the film's — and character's — most prominent
advocate, going as far as to say that his
character has the upper hand over Superman.
"The truth is: I was born to play Black Adam."
Considering the ever-growing list of canceled DCEU
movies, the fact that "Black Adam" is so close to
release is a near-miracle. As criticism over the
Warner Bros.-backed films has been inconsistent,
the powers-that-be have dropped the
proverbial axe on multiple planned projects.
This includes a Cyborg solo feature, a "Justice
League" sequel, and a slew of other unrealized
movies at various points in pre-production.
Most recently, "Batgirl" had concluded filming
and was all but set for release before studio
heads trashed the feature. Yet, "Black Adam,"
with a dark cape flapping past, has narrowly
skimmed through the multiple termination sprees.
The tumultuous road to publication didn't
stop once the cameras started rolling either.
"Black Adam" faced further obstacles during
production that ranged from coping with a
global pandemic to overcoming troublesome scores
from test screenings. Worrisome test scores had
"Black Adam" rated equal to the now-canceled
"Batgirl" movie. The Rock-lead feature was
forced into reshoots with the studio unwilling
to scrap the reportedly $185 million project.
Before diving further into speculation and
character analysis, there are some nuts and
bolts about the film worth covering. Officially,
the movie has not announced a runtime; however,
a parents guide from Filmy Rating has the
movie clocked in at 1 hour and 48 minutes.
Based on previous DCEU films, the
108-minute watch seems a little short,
with "Shazam!" clocking it at 132 minutes,
and the longest movie in the franchise,
"Zack Snyder's Justice League," lands at an
astounding 242 minutes. Yet, 2020's "Harley Quinn:
Birds of Prey" finished at 109 minutes, making
a shorter "Black Adam" film a real possibility.
Equally, "Black Adam" has not yet received
an official rating from the Motion Picture
Association of America. However, there is much
less need for speculation. According to Dwayne
Johnson's production company, Seven Bucks,
"Black Adam" was filmed intentionally aiming
for a PG-13 rating. Despite the rise of R-rated
comic book films, the story of the antihero did
not call for the additional profanities seen
in movies like "The Suicide Squad." But there
is reason to believe that "Black Adam" will
lean towards the harder end of the PG-13 rating
as the intense violence and visuals showcased
in the trailers suggest a darker DCEU movie.
Although he often crosses paths with Shazam's
Captain Marvel and shares the same lightning
bolt across his chest, Black Adam's powers differ
from his red-suited nemesis. Most prominently,
Captain Marvel — the DC version — gains his powers
by calling out an acronym of six Greek gods,
while Black Adam, who also yells "SHAZAM," is
bestowed his abilities by Egyptian gods. The
stamina of Shu offers Black Adam endurance and
sustenance, meaning he can live without food,
water, or air. The god Horus gifts him
superhuman speed and flight. Strength equal
to that of Superman comes from Amon. Meanwhile,
the wisdom of Zehuti and the power of Aten make
Black Adam not only super-intelligent but
able to use magic — an ability that often
gives him the upper hand. And finally, the
courage of Mehen makes him invulnerable.
Needless to say, Black Adam is a powerhouse of
super abilities equal to — and often surpassing
— the strongest we have seen, like Superman
and Captain Marvel. However, the character is
not without his limits. Most interestingly,
yet inconsistently explored in the comics,
the 5000-year-old Adam is stuck in his powerful
form. Unlike the hero of "Shazam!," Black Adam
can't transform back and forth between superhero
and child by saying one word. If he were to revert
to his original self, his body would disintegrate,
aging the thousands of years that have passed.
As a character, Black Adam has been around since
1945, when Fawcett Comics still published Captain
Marvel and the rest of the Shazam family,
long before their rights were sold to DC.
His true name is Teth-Adam, and he was bestowed
powers by the same wizard that appears in the
"Shazam!" movie. However, instead of using
his powerful abilities to protect the world,
Adam decided that he should be its ruler and
assumed the throne of Egypt. Betrayed, the
wizard banished the errant champion to the most
distant star in the universe. Taking thousands of
years to return to Earth, Black Adam arrives
to find a new champion has taken his place.
Surprisingly, the Shazam villain only appeared
the once under the original publisher.
It was not until DC owned the rights that
Black Adam would return in 1975. Since then,
the character has been prominently utilized
as a villain to DC's most powerful heroes,
including Captain Marvel, Superman,
and the Justice League. At times,
Black Adam has reformed, becoming a hero,
but he is often portrayed as an antihero,
defending his own beliefs of what is
good and protecting his home of Khandaq.
A significant inclusion in the upcoming "Black
Adam" movie is the cinematic introduction of
the Justice Society of America. As much as this
collective of superheroes seems like a derivative
of Justice League, the JSA predates the latter
by two decades. The original concept behind the
Golden Age team was to combine characters
from two sister companies into one series,
All-Star Comics. The blended stories included
members from both DC Comics and All-American
Comics until 1946, when the characters
were amalgamated under one publisher title.
DC Comics later rectified the inconsistent
storylines in the 1985 limited series "Crisis
on Infinite Earths," canonically making the
JSA a defunct World War II-era super team.
The earliest members of the JSA included
characters that have now become extremely popular,
including Green Lantern and Flash. However,
much of the initial lineup remains intact
for the upcoming "Black Adam" film —
specifically Doctor Fate and Hawkman,
while Atom Smasher is a descendant of
the original Atom. Throughout the years,
there have been new iterations of the JSA
introducing new members along the way.
Meanwhile, the team has appeared on multiple
DC television shows, including "Smallville,"
"Legends of Tomorrow," and "Stargirl." And
depending on the reception of "Black Adam,"
Warner Bros. is receptive to the idea of creating
a spin-off movie for the unique team of heroes.
"Make this one count."
The DCEU timeline is loose, potentially broken,
and not nearly as streamlined as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. The pair of "Wonder Woman"
movies fill points in a timeline that seemingly
centers around the 2017 "Justice League" feature.
However, the inconsistent double header of 2016's
"Suicide Squad" and James Gunn's "The Suicide
Squad," mixed with differently aged actors
portraying Batman, convolute a cinematic universe.
A universe that is about to get even messier with
an upcoming "The Flash" movie that reportedly
involves significant time travel. The whole
order of things is difficult enough to keep sorted
without including another time-spanning character.
So, where does "Black Adam" fit into the
DCEU timeline that is otherwise fractured?
As seen in the released trailers, the
story begins thousands of years ago,
making it simple to choose an awakening point
to align with certain characters and events.
With news that Viola Davis's Amanda Waller
character from "The Suicide Squad" is set to
appear in "Black Adam," the story will likely
take place in the modern day after the events
of "Justice League." The choice to bring Black
Adam into the DCEU as it currently stands would
simplify any future throwdowns with established
characters such as Superman and Shazam.
However, an explanation will be necessary for
why the Justice Society of America is reacting
to the film's events instead of characters
that previously existed in the universe.
As a wrestler, one of Dwayne
Johnson's most famous lines goes,
"Can you smell what The Rock is cooking?"
The phrase holds some depth nowadays as the a-list
movie star is intentionally stirring the DCEU pot.
Johnson is putting much stock in his new
superpowered character to pave the way for
a revived DC cinematic collection. During his
arrival at the 2022 San Diego Comic-Con event,
a large screen behind him boldly stated,
"The DC Universe will never be the same."
During the Hall H trailer premiere, The
Rock doubled down on the statement, saying,
"The idea [behind the film] was: How can we create
something that’s fresh, unique, maybe show and
create things that have never been done? [...]
Maybe we can issue a new era in the DC Universe,
maybe it’s time for a shift, get in there and
disrupt a little bit and listen to the fans."
Given the unstoppable popularity of superhero
films and the universal approval of Dwayne
Johnson's electric charm, it seems natural
for DC to want to sign the former wrestler
up for a trilogy of movies. Truthfully, they
hit the lottery when the big-name star found a
character he resonated with so deeply within
their roster instead of the competitors.
Unfortunately, DC projects are on shaky
ground at Warner Bros. Studios. So,
the future of Dwayne Johnson's character in
the DCEU highly depends on the reception of
his inaugural outing. Producer for Johnson's
Seven Bucks Productions company, Hiram Garcia,
spoke about the potential
follow-up with Collider, saying,
"We have big plans, obviously, for the DC
Universe, if the fans perceive the way we want."